so interestingly enough there's not
actually that much to cover from cpac
the conservative political action
conference we covered donald trump's
speech
earlier in the show uh and there's only
a few other things to say
cpac you know at one point cpac really
was one of the more important
right-wing conferences with many big
players from the american right
and this past weekend cpac was more like
a
racist transphobic religious
comic-con than a serious gathering and i
don't even want to insult comic-con like
comparing cpac to comic-con comic-con
has a lot of really interesting things
comic-con has lots of
uh great sci-fi writers and a lot of
interesting things i think i would learn
a lot more actually
by going to comic-con than i would from
cpac so i'll put it a different way
i would much rather go to comic-con than
cpac not only would it be more
informative
i'd meet more interesting people and
people more grounded in reality
in any case comic-con sort of analogies
aside
one of the notable speeches was ted cruz
ted cruz is the now
very much beleaguered senator who
recently had
had to cut his cancun vacation short
because it exploded into a public
relations nightmare when he fled to
mexico with his family
as his own constituents in texas were
without power sometimes without heat
struggling even to get food water had to
be boiled
many times with electricity they didn't
have ted cruz went to cancun
so ted cruz goes to cpac and he appeared
to have sort of like a manic episode his
speech ended with a completely
hyperbolic
crescendo of screaming which we'll get
to but ted cruz first opening with a
joke
about wanting to be back in cancun i
guess
god bless cpac
[Applause]
i gotta say orlando is
awesome
[Applause]
it's not as nice as cancun
but it's nice so
really well-crafted comedy by the
republican senator really a wordsmith
and
uh public speaking uh expert as you can
see then
uh he ridiculously went after
senator bernie sanders and congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
we're actually going to come back to the
aoc part a little bit later but take a
look
bernie is wearing mittens
and aoc is telling us she was murdered
and the media desperately desperately
desperately wants to see
a republican civil war so this is like i
can't figure out if this is bad comedy
or
terrible political speech i i actually
can't tell which it is maybe it's both
ted cruz then going into an anti-mask
rant they're still on this mask stuff by
the way
how many of you all have eaten at a
restaurant in the last six months
can i just stop and say how strange the
rules are right now i want to understand
how this virus works so when you walk in
you got to put your mask on sadly i've
got two
you walk in you got to put your mask on
you sit down you take your mask off
see apparently the virus is actually
connected to elevation
now remember this is all about science
it's actually it may not be elevation i
think it's
it's that there are hormones that are
released in your thighs when you're
sitting
so you can sit at the table and there's
no virus being transmitted
but if you stand up put the mask on who
wrote this stuff
for ted cruz they should really be
writing for snl or the daily show i mean
great great material
for how you would ridicule a politician
giving a speech uh and then here is
where ted cruz
starts to kind of escalate and seemingly
get more and more manic
well they're saying everybody can get
immunized
we can have herd immunity everywhere and
we're gonna wear
masks for the next 300 years
and by the way not just one mask two
three four
you can't have too many masks
how much virtue do you want to signal
this is just dumb
ted cruz working himself up to actually
being sort of short of breath now and
of course as i've said many times before
the reason that public health experts
have to be
so cautious in what they say
about what an individual getting
vaccinated means
is that so many people like ted cruz
like his followers like the people at
cpac
they are desperate to disregard all
guidelines and measured
measures oh one person got vaccinated
let's hold a 50-person indoor party of
course
reasonable people know that vaccination
opens new doors for people and of course
as more people get vaccinated
we will be able to start backing off of
all the guidelines
but because of people like ted cruz
spreading disinformation
that we never needed masks and all of
this stuff all along was bogus
public health experts have to say just
because you got vaccinated don't go nuts
just because five percent of the
population has had two doses i don't
or whatever the number is i'm not caught
up we'll have a report tomorrow
doesn't mean everything can be
disregarded uh
ted cruz now is is uh and i've seen
unfortunately facebook friends posting
this too
if the vaccines change change nothing
why would i get a vaccine and of course
as we talked about last week in our
segment about
vaccine alarmism that's not the case but
the reason people have to continue being
so
careful with what they say from a public
health standpoint
is because of people like ted cruz okay
i'll i'll
interrupt this rant and do more of it
tomorrow
then here's the absolute end to ted
cruz's speech
screaming at the top of his lungs and
really appearing to lose it
in the immortal words of william wallace
freedom
so that's a senator one of 100 senators
in the collegial and storied legislative
body
that is the united states government the
united states senate within the united
states government
screaming at the top of his lungs
quoting mel gibson and braveheart
as an apparently defiant and principled
stand against wearing a mask during a
pandemic
this was one of the highlights of cpac
if you can imagine
most of the rest of it not even worth
covering but one theme that we did see
throughout cpac
is the inability to accept that donald
trump lost then i want to talk about
that next
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and thankfully
there is a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video